OK, good morning everyone.
It's 9:00 on the west coast.
I'm Alex Booth, the director of the BD2K Center's
Coordination Center.
Today, we're continuing section four on data
modeling and inference methods.
And one type of method, that some of you may
have already encountered in your own studies
or work-- or at least heard of-are related
to Bayesian techniques.
So I have the pleasure of introducing professor
Michael Newton, a professor of statistics
and bio-statistics, and medical informatics
at University of Wisconsin Madison.
Advance slide.
Good.
Great.
Dr. Newton is an associate director at the
Center for Predictive Computational Phenotyping--
CPCP-- one of the national BD2K centers of
excellence.
Dr. Newton has led many novel applications
of statistical techniques and algorithms on
biomedical big data.
For instance, he was the first to use Markov
Chain Monte Carlo in phylogenetic analysis,
as well as the use of mixture models for analyzing
high dimensional gene expression changes.
A longstanding interest of Professor Newton
is in the area of Bayesian and empirical Bayesian
computations.
And he'll be talking to us today about Bayesian
inference methods.
So please join me in welcoming Dr. Newton
this morning.
Michael, thank you for joining us.
The floor is yours.
Thank you, Alex.
Well, hello everybody.
It's great to be here.
Thanks for tuning in.
I do hope you find something useful in today's
webinar.
So the pics on this first slide signify some
projects and activities that I've been involved
in in my own work, and they may show up in
examples as we go through today.
Well, Bayesian inference is a big deal.
Lots of researchers have thought a lot about
it, and how it can be used to advantage in
data analysis.
There are a few books on the topic, and I
encourage you to take a closer look.
My goal today is to be sort of a cheerleader
for Bayesian methods, pointing out some of
their basic features, and also some opportunities
in this new world of data science.
But, in addition to my job, there are some
things for you to do, too.
You can join the Society for Bayesian Analysis.
You can check out the American Statistical
Association section.
You can check out online the journal, Bayesian
Analysis.
You could, in fact, visit Duke University,
where is one of the strong centers for Bayesian
inference and research in these techniques.
You could check out some code.
Andrew Gelman's originated this terrific code
project called Stan.
It delivers some really useful software techniques
for deploying Bayesian analysis.
So that's some of the things you can do.
I'm going to just give you a bit of an overview
of what Bayesian analysis is-- some of the
key features about it, and how it goes in
some examples.
So it's a general strategy for data analysis,
and it's based on probability.
And the key thing about it is it couples data
with some kind of model
specification.
And that model specification has two features.
It's got a probability structure for the data
themselves, given unknown things.
This reflects kind of the central dogma of
statistics-- that all data sets are the realization
of some random process.
And encoding that in probabilities is kind
of central.
But then the second part of it has to do with
all the unknown parameters, say.
And there's some probability structure on
that, too.
That's a special part of Bayesian analysis.
It essentially expands the domain of probability
to be a general measure of uncertainty.
And then inference about what we don't know,
given what we know, is perceived using the
rules probability.
OK, well, I'm talking about a few relevant
examples.
But I wanted to start with a kind of irrelevant
example-- but it's still pedagogically interesting--
about thumb tacks.
So here's a little video.
I'm doing an experiment to collect some data.
I'm tossing a thumb tack.
And notice that I tossed that tack, and it
landed with its point facing down.
I replicated that experiment again, and I
tossed the tack, and it happened to land with
its point facing up.
And this was the beginning of a longer experiment
that I did, with 50 trials, the outcomes of
which-- the full dataset-- is shown here.
I got, in my 50 trials, it turned out, 17
times that the tack landed with its point
facing down.
Now we know, from the law of large numbers,
the relative frequency at which the tack lands
with its tip point facing down-- that D over
n.
Relative frequency is-- well, it's a random
variable, for one thing-- but also, it stabilizes
in the long run.
If I were to have continued the experiment,
tossing tacks indefinitely, it would converge
to something we'll call theta.
The long run relative frequency of times that
the tack lands with it's head pointing down.
And that's a parameter of the system-- a property
of the tack in the experimental system.
And it's an unknown underlying parameter,
underneath the dataset.
So we could, of course, estimate that unknown
theta with 17 out of 50-- 34%.
But at issue, really-- in our focus are asking
more general inference questions, such as,
what are plausible values of that parameter,
having observed 17 tack points down in 50
tests?
And rather than go through the math of it,
I just wanted to answer this question a Bayesian
would answer, but through a simulation.
So in this first part of the simulation, suppose
we happen to know this long-run relative frequency,
theta.
If we did, we could certainly run the experiment
in the computer and replicate it.
So this little panel shows a sort of set up
to understand replications of this little
tack tossing experiment.
I've got possible values of theta on the horizontal,
and I've got possible values of data on the
vertical.
And the observed value of data is steep--
17 times that the tack faced pointing down
out of 50 trials.
Now look at the little code chunk up in the
upper right, here.
This is my in silico experiment.
I could fix theta, for instance, if I knew
it, at, say, 60%.
And set up this little code, which just is
a way of using pseudorandom numbers in the
computer to simulate the tack tossing without
actually tossing the tack 50 times.
But this a replicate of that, if
I knew that long run relative frequency.
And I happen, when I do that, to get about
26.
Now since it's a simple bit of code, I can
repeat it.
Obviously I can repeat it.
And look-- I did it about 1,000 times.
And this represents the so-called sampling
distribution.
You'll all recognize the binomial sampling
distribution of the relative values of the
number of point-down tacks out of 50, centered
around 60% of 50-- around 30-- but with some
fluctuation.
And notice that the observed value of 17 doesn't
look very plausible for that dataset.
And that's basically a problem with this little
simulation-- I've had to pretend I know the
value of this unknown parameter, but in fact,
I don't.
Now if I do that simulation, I could just
change it a little bit.
If you look up here, I just imagined what
data I might have gotten.
Let me also vary the value of the parameter
theta, by just grabbing a uniformly distributed
theta every time.
And on that uniformly distributed theta, then
go ahead and simulate my outcome of my experiment.
This is what you'd get, if you do it about
1,000 times.
Now what's round and gray there, is-- these
are hypothetical repetitions of the experiments
that I've set up, in this two-stage experiment--
where the simulated data actually is exactly
the same as the data that I happen to see
in my real experiment.
So surely, those values or those parameters,
that gave rise to those simulated data, must
be plausible.
Because in light of the data that I saw, they
could easily have given rise to the same data,
as we saw on the simulation.
So that is the essence of what Bayesian analysis
is.
It's looking at the distribution of those
theta values.
Now we've conditioned, effectively, on that
17, and we can project down onto the theta
axis right now.
And so I've just taken this and boosted the
simulation size up a bit.
But this is the distribution of thetas that
came out of this experiment, where I first
simulated theta, and then I get simulated
data, given theta.
But then I keep track of the theta that matches
my observed data.
These are certainly plausible values.
Well indeed, mathematically, we can work out
the formula for that curve.
It's known as the posterior distribution.
Functional form is known, and it expresses
a kind of uncertainty in the value of data
that would have generated the data we saw,
but that uncertainty expressed after the data
have been seen.
That's to contrast it with the uncertainty
that we expressed in this little simulation
before the data were seen.
Remember that runif chunk of code that said
what the theta values are before, what theta
values I'm considering as relevant, in advance
and having seen the data.
And this connection, the famous formula that
the posterior is proportional to the prior
times the likelihood-- this likelihood now
coming from the binomial model, in our case--
goes way back to Thomas Bayes himself.
Now looking at that functional form, this
thing, this beast, is the object that is critical
for inference.
So we could take-we don't know that theta.
We have a summary of our uncertainty about
it.
If we take the center value, the mean of
we don't know that theta.
We have a summary of our uncertainty about
it.
If we take the center value, the mean of that
distribution-- its expected value-- that could
serve as a point estimate.
And that happens, in this case-- that the
balance point of the distribution is a little
different than what you would think of as
the natural estimator, 17 or 50.
It's a little bit modified.
It's, as we say, shrunken towards the prior
mean, which is a half compared to the NLA.
We could also get an interval that contains
a certain amount of posterior probably.
So that's how it would go in this little toy
example.
Now let's take a second, less-toy example--
intestinal tumors.
Now here, the data aren't outcomes of a tack
throwing experiment, but they're outcomes
of looking inside the DNA of polyps that were
found during colonoscopy of men in a study.
Detectable pathogenic mutations from 36 colon
polyps.
Here's the data, here.
The horizontal corresponds to the 36 different
subjects in the study.
The vertical, or the rows, correspond to different
pathogenic mutations that were measured, assessed,
by sequencing different genes that are known
to be critically involved in the development
of colon cancer.
That's the data.
These are detectable, so they have to have
appeared at a sufficiently high frequency
in the sequencing of the tumor.
This comes from a recent publication by Chelsie
Sievers and Rich Halberg's group here in Madison.
OK, before I tell a bit about the model, I
have to say something about colon cancer progression.
This little cartoon on the left shows just
a tiny segment of the wall of the intestinal
epithelium.
And the green piece here has been converted.
It's initiated.
It's non-normal, and it's starting to become
cancerous.
And the polyps are essentially at this stage.
The data is coming at this stage-- early abnormal
growth outside of this structure here.
And eventually, if things go wrong, you will
get a cancer.
But the data that we're talking about are
data early [INAUDIBLE] stage.
I also want to point out a basic structural
unit of the intestinal wall that's expressed
here in cross-section in this cartoon.
The intestinal wall is made up of millions,
I guess, of these barrel-shaped glands called
crypts.
There are actually thousands of cells, not
just a handful of cells here.
And they're clonal, so essentially they all
come from stem cells at the bottom of the
space.
They're from a single lineage.
That's going to be important in something
I'll say later.
They are from a single lineage.
And they are the basic structural unit of
the intestine, like I said.
And also tumors, when they start, initially
adenomas, they emerge out of these crypts,
and they start to grow.
There's a whole bunch of interesting things
about crypt biology I won't say, but the crypt
itself is going to be an important thing for
my story.
OK, so previously we tossed tacks in silico,
but now instead of tossing tacks in silico,
I'm going to do a simulation of tumor growth.
It's a discrete-step simulation.
It's not cells that are shown here, but actually
crypts that proceed.
This evolved by a certain stochastic model,
which you can read about in the papers.
Actually, crypts may fission.
They turn into multiple crypts, or they potentially
die.
And also, the crypts, these clonal bodies
may incur certain mutations as they go on.
The colors that you may be able to see here--
there's different colors-- correspond to different
mutations that have occurred and then grown
out.
So this is an interesting thing.
So it's not tossing a tack, but it's growing
a tumor.
Now, what did Sievers do?
They would simulate these tumors, and then
they'd mimic the sampling process.
They did an in silico section of the tumor,
looked at the crypts inside.
Basically, we're trying to match what they
observed here with our observed data on the
36.
In the Sievers paper, they do something very
light.
Instead of conditioning on all 36, they just
ask a very, very simple question.
It's a little bit different than finishing
all the data.
They just asked, at the level of a mutation
that you would see in here, does the frequency
at which that mutation occur, does it exist
at a sufficiently high frequency to be detected
by the next-generation sequencing technology
that's used?
And there's a lower threshold, that the mutant
frequency had to be bigger than 10% in order
for the sequencing to observe.
Is it a detectable mutation?
Now, ideally, in fact, we would simulate not
just one tumor up to check for its mutation,
but we would simulate a sample of these polyps
or tumors.
And you'd see if the mutation profile in slices
of these things matched our observed sample.
We don't do that.
Sievers didn't do that.
But I'd just point interested observers to
this paper, just came out earlier this week,
by Marjoram's group that does essentially
that kind of a calculus.
In any case, in the simple calculation that
we're talking about, where we simulate up--
instead of tossing a tack, we're simulating
a tumor that's growing in the intestine through
a stochastic model of how tumors might grow,
and we look at a mutation that's shown up
at the time that we observe the tumor.
The quantity of interest in Sievers' paper
was the size of the tumor in crypts when the
mutation that we're looking at happened to
have emerged.
So when we see it at observation time, we
get to see a mutation at some frequency.
But that mutation must have emerged in the
tumor growth sometime before we got to observe
it.
That time isn't known to the observer.
That's the parameter theta sub mu.
And the simulation's rigged up so that these
mutations can emerge at any time along the--
they can emerge at any time, in the sense
of any size that the tumor is as it's growing.
But if we condition on the data, so to speak,
that we condition on the fact that the mutation
actually exists at sufficiently high frequency
to be detectable when we measure it, then
we get a posterior distribution of the size
of the tumor when that mutation arose.
And looking at these kind of distributions
tells us that these detectable
mutations must have arisen when the tumor
was actually quite small.
And you can get specific inferences about
that.
So that's an interesting variation of the
simulation story, where instead of simulating
tacks, we're simulating tumors.
But the same story-- you simulate unknown
things, data-- simulated data until that data
is equal or approximately equal to the observed
data that you have.
And you keep track of the quantity theta that
corresponds to it.
This simulation view of the Bayesian inference
was one of a number of terrific insights made
by Don Rubin in his paper that I recommend
highly to everybody on the frequency calculations
that are relevant for Bayesian analysis.
That's also the basis of what people are gonna
call approximate Bayesian computation.
That's especially useful in situations where
the likelihood functions are intractable,
such as in population genetics or other forms
of ancestral influence.
So that's just a little, I suppose, to whet
your appetite about Bayes from a simulation
perspective.
I want to talk about three main features of
Bayes going forward now with the rest of my
time.
So I want to talk about three basic things--
handling uncertainty, combining different
data sources, and borrowing strength.
And I'll use three different case study examples
to illustrate these features of Bayesian inference.
So let's go forward.
Handling uncertainty-- so this is one of the
sort of basic features of Bayes, that we understand
that data doesn't tell us all the information.
Even if it's big data, it doesn't have-- for
things we're interested about, it may not
contain all the information.
So we have to be able to express our uncertainty
about things that we don't quite know.
And Bayes is rigged up for that.
So let's say that in addition to a parameter
theta that we might be interested in, there's
some other parameter, psi.
And Bayes' procedure somehow or other through
a model specification gives rise to a joint
posterior distribution of all the unknowns
given the data that we have.
Well, if we're really just interested in theta,
somehow, then-
Michael, we're having problems with the audio.
Could you please check your microphone?
Hello?
Ah, you're back.
I think that sounds better.
OK, keep going.
Well, should I back up some?
I mean, I don't know how long I was-
We lost you for actually a few minutes, so
maybe if you could just back up a little bit,
that would be good.
OK.
Sorry about that.
I don't know quite what happened.
Let's see if I can back up here.
Give me a sign here.
Do we know about this part?
I think that's good.
OK, so the handling uncertainty part, I'm
gonna try and talk about it in the context
of an example.
Would that be a good place to kick back in,
Alex?
Yes.
OK.
OK, sorry folks.
So this handling uncertainty, I'm going to
talk about in an example from RNA interference.
This is a genome-wide technology for understanding
gene functions.
And just briefly about that, you've seen the
slides but didn't hear me say it's a cell-based
assay.
The basic idea is you have a target gene that
you're targeting with a given siRNA.
You add that siRNA-- small interfering RNA--
to the cells.
And what it's supposed to do is knock down
the expression of that gene.
And if that targeted gene is involved in some
phenotype that you're measuring, then that
phenotype will change, and the cell will change
as I've indicated with the [INAUDIBLE].
And in the story, we're talking about the
phenotype that has to do with the cell's ability
to replicate virus.
There were four large-scale studies that used
this technology genome-wide.
And we had data on parts of these studies.
All studies had an interesting similarity.
They were two-stage studies with a detection
screen and a confirmation screen.
The whole genome was-- every one of the genes,
different siRNAs were used to try to knock
down things, and anything that passed a detection
screen went into a confirmation screen that
was more intensive, but it only had to be
applied to the things that were detected initially.
And remember, the detection has to do with
whether or not-the phenotype here is whether
or not a cell, when it's infected with virus
and you knock down the gene, whether that
changed the cell's ability to make virus.
And one of the curious things here, as in
other examples, is that, as I was saying,
each of the studies found about 200 genes
that they said when you knock them down, it
affects the cell's ability to replicate virus.
But only one gene was found in common to all
four studies.
Few genes were found in three of the four
studies, some in two of the four, but the
majority of genes that were identified and
reported as involved in flu were uniquely
identified in one study only.
Could be because of false positives.
Measurement error is one, but off targets
is a big possibility, where you add the siRNA,
and there's a change in the cell, as indicated
by the pink, but actually the gene that that
siRNA has targeted isn't really involved in
flu at all.
It's just that the siRNA accidentally, and
not by design, happens to knock down another
gene that is involved in flu.
And then you see the phenotype, even though
you shouldn't have really.
It could also be false negatives, and there's
a bunch of possible false negative results.
One where it's just-- the gene's really involved
in flu, but you're somehow not able to see
it when you do the siRNA screening.
For instance, you add the siRNA screen, you
knock down the gene that's really involved
in flu, but somehow or other there's another
gene sitting there that's doing the job of
the first gene in those particular cells,
and so even though the gene one has been knocked
down and is really involved, you don't see
a phenotypic effect in those cells.
There's various other forms for the negatives
and positives, but the big issue was whether
or not-- which is the source of disagreement?
If false positives were really a big deal,
you wouldn't be surprised to see a lack of
agreement, because each study is just pulling
up a bunch of random genes, and so it wouldn't
be surprising that you wouldn't have much
agreement.
But at the same time, it could be that flu
is really a big complicated thing, and that
each of the studies really is just seeing
a small part of it.
And [INAUDIBLE] underlie those singletons
really are true.
So as I was saying here, to bring it back
to the context of Bayesian analysis, we have
a probability model for the data we were able
to compile, and the data that we're able to
compile is a kind of meta-analysis of what
happens to each gene across each of the studies,
whether or not it was detected and whether
or not it was confirmed.
And we have counts, for instance, of how many
genes.
There were four genes that were detected in
the first study and confirmed.
They were detected in the second study and
not confirmed, and they weren't detected in
the second two studies.
Naturally, a multinomial likelihood.
And that's the green, is the data that we
have, the detection and confirmation information.
But we don't know a lot of things.
We don't know whether the gene's really involved
in flu.
We don't know if it's accessible or if there's
redundancies.
In that case, we don't know off targets in
that study for those siRNA is used.
And we don't know a bunch of things generally
about the system as a whole, about the rates
of measurement error and efficiency.
We have bits of information about that, but
all those things we don't know.
We can put our heads together and try and
figure out a probability model that links
together all those things we don't know with
what we know.
You often see these [INAUDIBLE] basically
graphical representations of probability models
to express dependencies, and that's what that
is here.
So we use the tools of Bayesian analysis to
come up with a probability distribution of
the unknowns, given from what we do see.
So without going into any of the details of
how the calculations go ahead, we work out
a joint posterior distribution, and then we
come down to the statement of marginal posterior
distributions on quantities that we're actually
directly interested in-- these error rates.
So for example, theta 1 is the quantity of
interest.
It's the false discovery rate.
It's something we don't know in advance, really.
It's the chance that the gene would really
be involved in flu if, in fact, it was confirmed
in the study.
It's the chance that the gene is not involved
in flu, and that's [INAUDIBLE] given that
it's confirmed.
So if it's confirmed, what's the chances it's
not involved?
That's a false discovery rate.
This is a kind of a false positive rate.
Well, we don't know that false positive rate.
But in our calculation, we get a posterior
distribution for the false positive rate.
That's way down here.
And similarly, we get a distribution for the
false negative rate.
And this and some other similar calculations,
basically they've accounted for all of the
uncertainty, and all those many, many things
that we didn't know in the context of a specific
probability specification.
And it tells us pretty unequivocally that
false negatives are a bigger problem than
false positives.
And that lines up with some other analyses
of the same data.
But that's an example of using marginal posteriors
to get particular quantities of interest and
address those.
I want to move on to another example-- combining
data.
One of the big things about Bayes is that
you can combine multiple data sources.
So I'm gonna talk about different data, x
and y coming together to make inference.
This is a story about cancer, and it's based
on this amazing creature called an aggregation
chimera that is formed from two early embryos
that are fused together and implanted into
a foster mother.
And then once in a while, if it all works
right you get some animal out that's really
two separate animals more or less merged together--
four parents.
Here's a chunk of the intestinal epithelium
of one of these animals that's also been genetically
engineered to be susceptible to growing tumors
in their intestine.
And it's blue and white color owing to the
two separate parental lineages.
The blues come from one side, and the whites
come from another.
Now, curiously, in the middle-- it's a little
hard to see, but in the middle is a tumor.
And what's especially curious about it is
that it's two colors.
It's blue and white.
About 20 percent, in fact, of the tumors is
this animal are heterotypic.
Now, the standard story about biology, cancer
growth, which of course we can't-- one of
the cool things about cancer research is that--
statistics for cancer research is you're talking
about events that happen before you're able
to observe them.
But the standard story about tumors growing
out of crypts, crypts being clonal, doesn't
work
here, because if it did, they would be either
pure white, because the cells in one lineage
are either white or pure blue, but they wouldn't
be mixed together.
So this is a kind of a polyclonality story.
Now, there's a bunch of interesting statistical
issues with the polyclonality.
I just want to focus on one specific one,
about combining information sources.
So one information source has to do with the
patchwork of the cell tissue of this lineage.
Some of the cells come from one lineage.
One of the originating embryo [INAUDIBLE]
comes from the other, so that patchwork, the
beautiful patchwork that presents itself.
Now, we'd like to know-- in order to have
an understanding of tumor initiation events,
we'd like to know where the crypts are under
there.
But we don't get to see those.
Now, on the other hand, there's something
that-- well, just to back up, there's something
about the imaging technique that is not able
to reveal the positions of the crypts in the
blue and white images.
Now, there is data on other animals that aren't
animals that are chimeric animals, but there
are data on other animals-- or at least they're
not blue-white imaged animals-- that show
what these crypts' organization look like.
So we'd like to kind of merge-- fuse this
data with this data somehow.
And that's what the analysis that I'll show
tries to do.
The reason we want to do this is because we're
trying to understand how many pairs of crypts
are really on edges between blue and white
that could potentially give rise to these
clonal tumors.
So the data one side, the X, is a pixel image,
a blue-white image, the unknown quantity theta,
the positions that we record as centers of
positions of crypts.
And it's easy with some simple image analysis
ideas to work out a likelihood.
If you knew where the crypts were, what's
the probability of seeing a particular image?
You know that the crypts are pure blue or
white.
There would be some flip error at some small
rate which would flip a pixel.
If it's supposed to be white, it might be
blue.
And then if you're a pixel that's not over
a crypt, you might be coming up [INAUDIBLE]
background rate.
So that's one part.
Now, we also have a second data source, I
was saying, about the positions of crypts,
not in the data that we're interested in,
the blue-white image, but in another source.
We can triangulate that image and look at
those points.
They're not scattered uniformly randomly around.
In fact, they have quite a bit of spatial
structure that we can express with a kind
of spatial model on positions, where we use
the actual entry point distances to get an
estimate of this potential function for the
distribution of spatial positions.
So we've [INAUDIBLE] put that together.
We use the external data Y to tell us about
what kind of patterns we might expect to see
in the crypt orientation theta, and we want
to use that to get-- we take the blue-white
image together to try and figure out what
the crypt position might have been, in fact.
This is one sample from the posterior distribution
of the crypt position that I blow up here,
and I've colored the
crypts either blue or white, depending on
the majority color of the pixels above them.
And the key thing had to do with these red
edges.
These are neighboring crypts that are of opposite
color.
So if a tumor might emerge from crypts nearby
like that, there would be a certain rate at
which that happens that we can estimate.
And then based on this, we could get some
idea about what the interaction distance might
be in between crypts that are at the origin
of polyclonal tumors.
OK, that's a quick run-through of combining
information.
And in the last part, I want in the last few
minutes to talk about borrowing information--
borrowing strength, or information sharing.
This is a big deal in genomics.
You've got possibly many different but related
inference problems.
There are m of them, and I've got thetas are
the unknown parameters in each one.
And each one gives rise to a data set.
They're separate but related, in some sense.
Now, there's two cases.
The problems may be linked by some other parameter,
psi.
We don't know any other thetas or the psis.
We get the data.
Now, it's a classic result, going a long time
ago, that if you're interested in inference
about the psi, that unknown linking parameter,
you could screw up.
Even if you get lots and lots of data, your
standard estimates-- simple maximum likelihood
estimate-- won't be consistent for that underlying
parameter.
Goes back to Newman and Scott, 1948.
Just a few years later, though, Kiefer and
Wolfowitz showed you could do a trick.
You've got a lot of those theta parameters,
and if instead of just treating them as unknown
quantities, you treated them as unknown quantities
that came from a distribution, and you accounted
for the fact that there was such a distribution.
Even if you didn't know it, you could get
an estimate that now is still an MLA, a maximum
likelihood estimate, but it's acknowledging
that the thetas are coming from a distribution
of essentially random effects.
Then you could get consistent estimates of
the unknown.
So there was something just about having lots
of parameters.
When you had them, you ought to treat them
as if they're from a population.
That turned out to be important.
And here's another related thing that happened
long ago, too.
Here's a parameter.
I'll tell the story in three dimensions.
There's three unknown related but separate
problems.
Three unknown quantities-- theta 1, theta
2.
And I'm going to get three data points-- D1,
D2, D3.
And the sampling model is that the data are
independent, centered on theta.
So D1 is a data measurement that's estimating
theta 1.
D2 is estimating theta 2.
D3 is estimating theta 3.
But they're independent things, so D1 has
no effect on D2, and so on.
The little code chunk on the right is actually
trying to simulate that-- simulates this for
various thetas.
In fact, in this little code, I want to fix
theta 1, fix theta 2, and I want to run on
a grid of theta 3 to show a picture.
I simulate up some data.
Now, the question is, if I use the data--
I want to use the data somehow to estimate
the unknown quantities, the thetas.
There's no psi in this story.
There's just unknown thetas.
I could use a standard estimate, which is
to use the data themselves as estimates of
their expected values.
That's the standard estimate, which I calculate
in this code, and I look at error of that
estimate in a way I'll show in a second.
And then there's another one, a Bayes-style
estimate.
I'll call it just Bayes-style.
It's the data, but I shrink it a little bit.
Just like back in the tack problem, where
there was shrinkage, there's a little shrinkage
here that is a factor that, in fact, depends
on the data.
Now, this is the plot of the error.
The separate but related problems had nothing
to do with each other.
The noise had nothing to do with it.
But I'm going to assess the error of an estimator
by combining the problems together, and look
at the average squared difference between
the estimator and the thing it's estimating
accumulated up over the three different problems.
If I took the standard estimator, that mean
squared error is in the blue here, according
to that simulation.
I'm fixing theta 1, theta 2, and I'm just
letting theta 3 vary, just because it's hard
to draw in three dimensions.
If instead I was looking at the error not
of the standard estimator, but the error here
of the Bayes estimator, I get Bayes-style
estimator, I'll call it.
You get uniformly smaller-- uniformly smaller.
So this is a fundamental finding from way
back, that if performance evaluation considers
all the tasks that once, all those related
but separate problems, then the ideal procedure
for the whole thing is not taken by assembling
the ideal procedures for each problem taken
in isolation-- a fundamental fact that James
Stein figured out, and that in fact, you can
actually do better in frequency terms by using
some kind of a Bayesian-style procedure.
OK, how does this actually work?
Well, go back to the Keifer-Wolfowitz story.
You've got a bunch of related but separate
problems.
I have unknown quantities, data, and I'm going
to now treat them as if they come from a distribution
in order to try and get some benefit.
But of course, in reality, I don't know--
I know the data, but I wouldn't know the distribution
that generated it.
Of course, I have data, so maybe I could somehow
or other estimate that distribution.
Now, as I've estimated it, now I can think
like a Bayesian and say, well, I have that
distribution called g, which is essentially
[INAUDIBLE] and formulate a prior distribution
before I get data, essentially, associated
with all the parameters.
So I can do a Bayesian-style calculation by
working out the posterior proportional to
that prior times the likelihood piece.
And here-- this is the borrowing information
part-- this actually-- I'm doing inference
on a single unit, but this has acquired information
from all of the other units in this two-stage
process.
OK, so borrowing information is used a lot
in genomics.
I'm just going to close out with an example
of RNA-seq, is
used for measuring transcripts quickly.
We get samples of cells.
Messenger RNAs are extracted and converted
to cDNA.
They're read by next-gen sequencing reads.
Those reads are aligned with the genome.
We get some measures-- rough, raw measurements
of how frequent those RNAs are in the sample
of cells.
We have to do some computation to get abundance
estimates.
You'll get multiple samples together.
You'll normalize them to account for sampling
specific artifacts.
And then we'll get down here to a problem
of differential expression.
We want to know which genes are significantly
differentially expressed across different
conditions.
And the basic data structure that comes into
the calculation-- we've got genes on the rows.
We got different samples along here, and the
samples can be bundled up into multiple conditions.
The basic measurement, after all that processing,
is some basic measure of expression abundance
of a gene i in the sample.
I'm going to just say briefly something about
a popular technique called EBSeq, which is
deploying one of these information-sharing
tools in the context of expression.
And it's a popular one because it has some
nice statistical properties.
You can get it at those places.
Let me say quickly, I'm at my 11:50, but I'm
just going to just finish up with a couple
of slides on the structure of this if that's
OK, Alex.
Yes, it is.
Keep going.
Thanks.
So how does the structure of this thing go?
You've got multiple cell conditions.
You've got gene level parameters.
So these are parameters that have something
to do with the distribution of the expression
of measurements in each condition.
[INAUDIBLE] replicated expression profiles
in various conditions-- one, [INAUDIBLE] two,
and so on.
And each gene i is going to have some property.
So for example, if we took the negative binomial
distribution, which is an overdispersed--
a natural distribution to use for count data,
I show for two different thetas here possibly
two different conditions on a given gene,
what the sampling distribution of the counts
might be like for different for expression
values here.
If 0.1 was the expression, then if theta of
0.1 was the value, then this would be the
fluctuation we'd expect to see of expression
measurements in that condition.
So this is a natural probability distribution
to use.
Many people use it.
But how can you use it in a way to borrow
strength?
At issue are, you want to find genes where
there may be really some difference in the
thetas between conditions.
So coming to the borrowing strength part,
we have a bunch of related but separate problems,
those being all the different genes.
And we have parameters theta, one for each
gene, and each one is a vector over the different
conditions.
And the key structure of EBSeq is to do a
first discrete mixing over so-called patterns
of agreement and disagreement between the
condition-level distributions.
And then for any latent variables-- so that's
a finite sum here.
I'll give a quick example of that subsequently.
And then you'll still have unknown thetas.
Even for a given pattern, you'll have unknown
thetas, and they'll come out of some mixing
distributions.
EBSeq also has some extra bells and whistles
that handle isofarms nicely, and some other
things I won't say anything about.
So that's a specific structural model for
that distribution g.
And we want to learn that from the data, so
we use the [INAUDIBLE] to do it.
Once we've learned it, we can apply Bayesian-style
calculation.
What's the probability of a given pattern
given data?
And here's where the patterns come in.
For instance, one pattern-- if you have two
conditions, one pattern is that the thetas
on that gene for the two conditions are the
same.
There's just the no-differential expression.
There's no real difference between the two
conditions and the average expression of the
gene.
Or another pattern might be there really is
a difference in expression on the average
between those two conditions and the expression
of that gene-- basic null hypothesis, alternative
hypothesis at the gene level.
But the key thing about EBSeq is it's leveraging
all the information across the genome to try
and improve sensitivity and improve statistical
properties of the final procedure.
A part of that are local so-called local FDRs--
probability of the null being true given the
data.
And the list of discovery genes would be the
things where that null probability is small.
And then if the null is small, then there's
a high probability of the alternative.
So these are posterior probabilities calculated
[INAUDIBLE] the model, and there's a bunch
of nifty formulas that you can work out for
those probabilities in the case that's considered.
This just shows in a stem-cell example how
it would deploy, where there's two conditions--
human embryonic stem cells, induced pluripotent
stem cells, different genes on this axis.
These genes were discovered by the EBSeq analysis
of 5 percent FDR.
And there were some nice features about that
about power and robustness that other methods
don't have such good properties on.
That's a pretty quick summary of that.
I want to just go to my final couple of slides
on closing remarks, and I appreciate your
attention.
Benefits of Bayesian analysis-- handling uncertainty,
as I tried to describe with the flu problem,
where you've got a whole bunch of things you
don't know, [INAUDIBLE] marginal posterior
structure, combining different sorts of information,
of data.
Bayes is natural for that using the rules
of probability.
Borrowing
strength when you have many related but separate
problems, and how you can use the collection
of those to improve their statistical properties.
There's a whole bunch of issues.
There's computational challenges.
Where a lot of statistical machine learning
procedures involve optimization, Bayesian
procedures use a lot of integration.
So there are some different issues that come
up, and there's a lot of challenges-- data
science challenges there.
A big issue, which I think is something we
all need to think about as we do this, is
that this is all built on model specifications,
and you can make mistakes when you specify
a probability model.
The specification might be too simple.
If it's too simple, you're not going to learn
much new from some-- compared to some simple
procedure.
If it's too complicated, well, you risk all
kinds of things.
You risk making mistakes in the deployment
of it.
You risk that it doesn't respect the properties
of the data sufficiently well.
So there's risks associated.
And then the question in any given situation
of the risks of making a screwy model specification,
do they outweigh the benefits of improved
power or improved sensitivity?
And then finally, this last, I'll say the
unknowns you don't know, you don't know.
Bayes is all about unknowns and knowns, and
a joint probability distribution over all
those things-- [INAUDIBLE] priors, the probability
distribution of the thing that you don't know,
and then the likelihood is the probability
the data that you will get to know conditional
on what you don't know.
And you work out a posterior distribution
of what you don't know given what you know.
Except it doesn't work if-- you can't put
a prior down on something you don't know if
you don't know that you don't know it.
And this is a fundamental issue that we have
to deal with.
The way it's dealt with in practice is essentially
through diagnostic procedures.
Obviously, all analyses are facing this thing,
but we have to be upfront about it.
And so any model-based calculations we ever
attempt to do, we need to accompany with predictive
checks and diagnostics to make sure that we're
not really fooling ourselves.
I just want to end by dedicating this short
lecture to Steve Fienberg, who passed away
too soon last year.
He was a tremendous figure, had done tons
of things for the field of statistics generally
and data science and Bayesian analysis, and
he had a positive impact on lots of people's
careers, and I want to thank him for his contributions.
And I just want to say thanks again to you
all for listening.
And I know it was quick, but the slides are
available for you to look over.
And here are some papers that I cited during.
So thanks very much.
Thanks, Michael.
That was a great overview for Bayesian inference,
and you covered a lot of ground in a very
short amount of time, and I appreciate what
a great job you did expanding a lot of the
more challenging concepts in this space.
We have time for one quick question, which
is somewhat linked to the last point that
you brought up about unknowns.
And I guess the challenge that we had a lot
of times when we're dealing with data sets
is one of
both missingness and sparseness.
So I don't know if there are any new techniques
that you could comment on in terms of the
Bayesian perspective of how to deal with those
two very separate issues, but if there are
recommendations or suggestions you could make
in that regard.
Well, I gather next week, I think, Lance Waller
is going to be talking about missingness,
so I'm sure he'll have more useful things
to say about the first issue of missingness.
But you're right.
I mean, very often where you're trying to
do your statistical analysis is in a kind
of a gray zone where there's really a lot
of stuff you don't have that you would like
to have.
And while that's a challenge, it's also a
bit of an opportunity.
It's like, what else are you going to do?
If you-- the Bayes strategy provides a sort
of general approach.
And then there's a lot of liberty that you
have in terms of how you approach it, and
what you do depends so much on the context
of the situation, exactly what the relevant
information that you have or the relevant
information that you don't know.
How can you usefully summarize the data, and
what parts of data should you not have summarized
away?
I think you need to sit yourself in this kind
of a Goldilocks scenario where the model might
be too simple, the model might be too complicated.
If the problem that you're addressing is sufficiently
important, you'll have enough time to think
hard about it, and you could try something
like this.
And essentially, what you need to do is write
down some kind of probability structure for
all those things that you don't know.
And exactly what that would look like, that
depends very much on the context, doesn't
it?
I would say that in some classical probability
models, like regression models, where sparsity
is an issue that's very often discussed with
these penalized estimation procedures, lassos
and all that, that more fully Bayesian tools
for understanding the good procedures in those
situations have recently been, I think, discovered
and debated.
So there is a group at work that's doing a
lot with that.
There's Nick Polson's group in Chicago that's
done a bunch of interesting things.
So there's the role and the structure of prior
distributions when there's sparsity.
So that is an active area.
Maybe that's as much as I can usefully say
about it at the moment, but yeah, it's a good
question.
Great.
Well, we're at 10 o'clock, so I want to thank
you for your time, and we'll end here.
OK.
Thanks, Alex.
Thank you.